there are a few things more climactic in
anime than a fight where the heroes band
together in order to defeat an
overpowered character yeah some people
find some of it cheesy these days but
i'm still a sucker for these kinds of
fights there's something magical about
an overpowered villain getting pushed to
the edge or outright falling into the
might of weaker characters working
together and that's what we're gonna be
talking about today here are my favorite
moments in anime where people work
together to take down an overpowered foe
and i'll give some rundown on why
they're part of my favorites and while
you sit back and prepare for the list
isn't it time to get some refreshments
to keep you company luckily i've got the
perfect deal for you introducing today's
video sponsor a double header featuring
tokyo treat and sakurako tokyo tree and
sakurako are subscription-based snack
boxes that serve to provide the most
authentic experience you can have as far
as japanese suites are concerned this
month is the best month to start getting
both of these boxes as these guys have
been working overtime in cooking up the
best sweets and snacks for this month's
exciting themes for tokyo tree you get
to experience the japanese tradition of
tsukimi which is translated as moon
viewing just like hanami tsukimi has
remained a staple and unique festival to
japan tokyo tree looks to bring that
experience to you with this month's box
featuring this rare flavor of kitkat
pond crackers and loads more sakurako
meanwhile has its own take on the event
partnering with the kyoto government to
bring us a box filled with joy i'm
talking snacks that pair perfectly with
japan's signature drink green tea you
get kyoto candy kyoto hojicha latte
pudding and crackers all pair
excellently with gyon tsujiri hojicha
tea a perfect blend of sweet smoky
goodness awaits so check out the link in
the description box and use code vinnie
to get five dollars off your first box i
guarantee you won't regret spending a
cent on this super good deal our first
boss fight is the battle against alkene
[Music]
i just can't gush hard enough about how
ranking of kings is one of the best
underdog stories we've seen in modern
anime it's got that childish art style
that turned people off but the journey
is definitely more than worth it it's
one of the best not just in the past
year or two but as far as the previous
decade goes wonder if that's a hot take
but i think that if we're going to look
at things from the critic's lens that
statement does hold up and something as
great as it deserves no less than an
epic confrontation amongst the immortal
alkene olga made an impact here
defeating everything in his path to
miranjo's side that path of destruction
continued against the main characters
with him overcoming budgie and the rest
of his opponents due to his immortality
it's pretty insane the guy's body just
won't go and it took boss's creativity
to finally put organs rampage down for
good i started with this fight because
while it's a great fight in an amazing
show the conclusion doesn't feel as
grand as a lot of the others we'll be
seeing later on this list one such
example is the gita fight
we're talking about everyone versus
gitia fight there are many instances of
such an fgo solomon movie technically
speaking that is but the finale was
mostly fujimaru switching servants so i
think it's more appropriate to feature
the one that came beforehand even if it
didn't get the job done how would you
say no to nero's big entrance along with
many servants coming in one by one
attacking the immortal gitia as someone
who's a fan of the game it was more than
a treat seeing these servants all throw
their attacks to gitia while probably
the best background music in the fgo
anime plays in the background it's like
going through a best of list as everyone
gets their five seconds of fame and
gitia actually takes the offense he ends
this particular fight with a rather
anti-climactic thanos snap but it just
makes the next mob fight the one
starring fujimaru all the more rewarding
[Music]
the altair fight in recreators episode
20 is something similar
this fight compared to the previous one
is similar in a sense that it's part
altair showing off her superiority like
gita as we head towards the climax of
recreators we get a treat in the form of
an episode long fight where it's pretty
much everyone giving their all at altair
and it not even mattering in the end in
spite of the realization that altai has
become the strongest being in the
universe the protagonists do soldier on
and a lot of them go down in a blaze of
glory even the heralded trump card
sirius doesn't get the job done a sirius
only became a vessel for altair to
control this fight was a fight that kept
me on the edge of my seat because i
legit can't think of any way altair
could be defeated after seeing
everything this is yet another example
of a fight that's unwinnable in the
conventional way like ogen was defeated
by ingenuity it would take something
more than direct fighting to put a stop
to altair
[Music]
we de-escalate a bit with princess
connect golem fight
actually de-escalate could be a misnomer
however this may not be a final boss of
any sort like the previous entries but
it doesn't mean that it's any less
intense or epic the golden fight happens
somewhere in the middle of the second
season and this is around the time that
things get real for princess connect
this arc marks the shift in tone where
the serious plot comes in and yuki's
backstory gets revealed and barring a
relatively light-hearted episode or two
the show never lets go of the momentum
it established with this fight this is
pretty much a standard arc finale where
the characters get to show their attacks
as they take on an army of foes flanking
the gigantic boss showing off the
signature moves i've grown up to love
from playing the game it helps that the
fight is really high stakes compared to
everything we've seen so far and it all
comes to a crescendo with pekkarin's
return and an epic instrumental
rendition of the opening theme
up next is the fight against the medium
in magi
here's a party with the fights we've
taken a look so far this is by far the
one with the most participants talk
about all the nations of the world
banding together to fight the strongest
most unkillable thing the series has
ever seen in the span of multiple
episodes the fight is quite the epic way
to close out the second season of magi
and i wouldn't have it any other way
this is the most climactic fight in the
entire series and it's appropriate that
we saw so many gin equips the
participants just keep adding up one by
one until sinbad brings the last batch
of people including powerful rulers we
haven't met before ironically the fight
ends just as the last remaining name
combatants harkuriu and judah arrive at
the scene albeit in a non-fighting role
if there is a gripe though it's that
this fight just took way too long
fighting the medium took around three to
four episodes but the showcases of power
we saw mainly from the cult empire more
than makes up for it
anyone else feel cheated when sao's
ironcrad arc ended while the prematurely
what was supposed to be a trench to the
top never came to pass as kirito ended
up clearing the game after a one-on-one
fight with the game master heathcliff
there was supposed to be this big
showdown awaiting our heroes at the top
and we never got to see it well ordinal
scale fixed it by giving us the showdown
that we deserved and after seeing what
this thing was capable of i guess the
characters should be glad they never got
to face it an incarnate of the radius is
one of the most overpowered boss designs
possible for a game like sao night
invulnerability and an insane healing
ability it took kirito and gang as well
as the health of players they met from
every game they played to that point as
well as arsenal's shot calling and their
ultimate sword skills to get this job
done it's very tough but boy does the
sequence feel rewarding when the dust
has finally settled i watched ordinal
scale during the premiere and the
electricity i felt inside the theater
when the fight took place is a testament
to how big of a deal this was to sao
fans it's all fans could ask for wrapped
up in one package for a final fight
[Applause]
[Music]
with how overpowered incarnate of the
radius was at least the good guys were
able to defeat it straight up that's not
the case for eisen
things were going too well for the
protagonist in the fake garage town arc
despite being billed as an all-out war
between the shinigami and the aranka the
body count does tell a different story
yeah circumstances were at play but the
shinigami pretty much almost swept
through the opposition suffering
practically zero losses borrowing a
fight or two meanwhile the espada and
the aranka all lose their fights one by
one until it's aizen versus the captains
and the wizards when aizen steps up the
war takes a completely different
complexion and he wastes no time
establishing superiority he quickly
makes short work of multiple captains
one shotting them including probably his
personal job at gomamura but the
captains and shinji band together and
come up with a pretty creative strategy
pooling their attacks together in a
synergistic game plan to finally get a
decisive stab on aizen poetic justice
considering it's torshiro delivering the
final blow but of course it doesn't work
and eisen pulls off the ultimate
trolling before one-shotting everyone
poor momo but i won't say i didn't
expect this did anyone actually think
that they were going to be eizen without
ichigo's involvement still the fight
itself versus isaac is pretty cool and
i'm pretty impressed with how the
shinigami combined their powers together
here why don't we push things up further
with another crazy overpowered
antagonist in utsuru
[Music]
no this placement isn't a way for me to
start power level debates between utsuru
and aizen but if you want to go ahead
and discuss that then please go ahead
however i want to put these overpowered
final bosses next to each other because
why not and while utsuru may not have
gone through the same one-shot spree as
aizen did the fight against him feels
even more epic fights like this are what
we really live for friends and foes of
the past coming together sharing a
common phone that they have to work hard
to defeat this battle also brought a lot
of previous plot threads to a close
everyone can think of different moments
as the best highlight in this sequence i
like gintoki getting such a good showing
but i think that gamawi fighting
alongside everyone is a strong contender
for my favorite moment here especially
after everything he's been through the
hard-earned victory at the end is the
icing on the cake for such an epic
climax
then we have madara
of course madura is here to join the fun
we've already seen madras solo an entire
squad i've seen him beat the guy gays
without breaking a sweat so we're off to
a good start here and one has to wonder
how naruto and team would fare against
someone like madara even with the tailed
beasts at their side naruto and sasuke
still come within inches of death
against madras sure they pulled off a
good showing but it's really just a
glorified showcase of power for the
naruto universe's most broken character
ever still it's really fun to see the
actual fight to see the tail beast fight
gagashi and obito working together and
everyone doing their part no matter how
ineffectual it all ended up being i'm
not sure if this will find its place as
my top three or so favorite fights in
naruto with how many great fights there
are but if it comes to the category of
many versus one fights this has to be
one of the most epic ones that the
series has given us
finishing the list is the fight against
father
how's this to finish our run of
overpowered final antagonists in the
world of full metal alchemist no one
comes close to father he's by far the
most powerful character being a virtual
god at the point of this final battle
and that's just what makes this final
battle so good seeing him fall to the
combined might of the supposed weakest
beings humans and it's not like everyone
became fodder against this overpowered
last boss everyone gets their hits in
but it's still not enough after all no
matter what we do there's just no way us
weaklings can defeat a god right and the
way the show gave that statement a
resounding no is nothing short of
inspirational he gets worn down bit by
bit and ed laying into him at the end
was so satisfying on all levels sure
it's not just the protagonists that did
father in even taking that into account
seeing father make mistakes on four does
give us a great message that there's no
one invaluable in this world it may not
be as full of fireworks and effects like
say the magi fight but in terms of
themes and messages this one's by far
one of the best fights i could put on
the list
any other favorite fights that you have
in mind them as usual you can comment
away and let me know about some of the
other great fights that people feature
teaming up against an overpowered
character if you had fun and want more
then why don't you check out the channel
and my other channel vinitube kai hop
onto the channel's discord server and
other forms of social media while you're
at it too there'll be more anime videos
to come where i share some of my
favorite moments or characters as well
as seasonal reviews and previews so make
sure you stay tuned but that's it for
now however i'll be taking my leave and
i'll see you again in the next one